foreign
if you want to start your career in
ethical hacking you might be confused
with the variety of certifications being
offered in the market today from Network
Specialists to system administrator
ethical hacking has become necessary in
today's digital driven world with every
factor of business moving to the cloud
with jobs in every department and the
competition certifications are the best
way to demonstrate your knowledge and
skill in the potential employer and
stand out from the crowd in this video
we will talk about the best
certifications that you should aim if
you want to get into ethical hacking
however if you want a comprehensive
Solution on how to prepare yourself for
these exams check out the cyber security
expert Masters program which will give
you the knowledge and abilities that you
should need to excel in this quickly and
expanding field
with the Best in Class program you will
discover through methods of safeguarding
your infrastructure such as preventing
data and information constructing risk
analysis mitigation and architecting
cloud-based security achieving
complaints and much more so let's begin
with the first and probably the most
well-known and well-regarded
certification in the ethical hacking
sector which is none other than ceh or
certified ethical hacker but before that
let's discuss the agenda for this slide
so first we'll discuss what is ethical
hacking and after that we'll see what is
certified ethical hacker moving ahead
we'll discuss about oscp which is
offensive security certified
professional after that we'll see
certified information system security
professional which is
cissp after that we'll talk about com
Tia Security Plus certification after
that we'll see certified Cloud security
professional now let's see what is
ethical hacking so what is ethical
hacking basically it's when a computer
expert tries to hack into a system or
network in order to find any
valuabilities or weaknesses that a
miscellaneous hacker could exploit the
difference is that ethical hackers do it
with permission from the owner of the
system and they don't use their skills
to do any harm so why is ethical hacking
important well as we do more and more
online the risk of cyber attacks
increases cyber crimes can steal our
personal information money and
identities ethical hacking helps to
protect us from these attacks by finding
weaknesses in our system before that bad
guys can exploit them let you know about
ethical hacking let's start with the
certifications so the first one is
certified ethical hacking cea
certification so this certification is
for people who want to learn how to
think like a hacker to protect computer
systems better
it covers topics such as scanning system
hacking torgins back doors viruses and
bonds and social engineering to earn the
ceh certification you need to pass an
exam now I'll tell you about the course
that we are offering so in order to
better defend business infrastructure
from data breaches you will learn the
sophisticated step-by-step purchases
used by hackers in this certified
ethical hacking 12. okay I'll tell you
about that so this is the program ceh
version 12 certified ethical hacker
right this course will cover topics like
information security overview and then
it will start telling you about
information security threats and attack
vectors penetration testing comp
Concepts hacking Concepts ethical
hacking Concepts information security
control and there are so many other
modules also that you can see here on
your screen so this is what you will
learn about from this course
so the link will be in the description
box don't worry about the link you will
also see there will be live classes on
every weekdays for this see there will
be weekly classes starting from the date
you will join after that so there will
be weekly classes for this course and
also we will so whenever you will take
this course you will have to take the
ceh exam so for that we'll give you the
exam voucher with this course as it's
mentioned here also on our
screens that will give exam voucher for
ceh right so now we have offensive
security certified professional which is
oscp certification it's a highly
respected and practically certification
in the field of cyber security
offensive security a leading provider of
information security training and
penetration testing services offers it
the oscp certification test and
individual's ability to identify and
exploit variabilities in the control and
safe environment
Hands-On certification required the
candidates to complete a 24 hours
penetration testing exam on a simulated
Network followed by a report on their
findings
to prepare for the oscp certification
candidate must complete the offensive
security certified professional course
this course also includes video lectures
and practical exercises and candidate
must demonstrate their skills through a
series of lab exercises employers highly
value the oscp certification as it
demonstrates the candidates ability to
think outside the box problem solved and
work independently it is also a
prerequisite for many high-level cyber
security jobs such as penetration tester
ethical hacker in summary the oscb
certification is challenging and
practically require Hands-On skills and
a strong understanding of cyber security
Concepts it's a highly requested in the
industry and can lead to many exciting
and well-paying job opportunities the
best part about the oscp certification
is the similar reality it has with ceh
when it comes to curriculum so learning
the technical aspect of one is sure to
prepare you for the other with very
little efforts so you can take up ceh
course from Simply learn and you can
also learn after that the oacb because
it's very similar to that okay now let's
talk about the cissp
so certified information system security
professional certification this is one
of the most well-known and respected
certification in the field it covers a
wide range of topics including security
and risk management asset security
security architecture and engineering
communication and network security
identity and access management security
assessment and testing and many more to
earn the cissp certification you need to
have at least five years of experience
in the field and pass an exam so you
need to pass an exam of cissp so now let
me open the cissp course for you so we
have this CA SSP training course you can
take up this course the link will be in
the description box and let me tell you
about the cissp okay so yeah this cissp
certification is regarded as the
Pinnacle of achievement in information
security
the cisp course will prepare you to
become an information assurance expert
who defines all areas of ID security
including architecture design management
and controls it is aligned with ISC to
cbk standards start with cissp training
now because the majority of ID Security
Professionals favor or require a ciss SP
certification you will cover topics like
I'll tell you about the content of the
course so you will cover topics like
this domain One Security and risk
management asset security communication
and network security and there are so
many domains in in this you will learn
so many other things so this is will
definitely going to help you the link
will be in the description box do check
it out click on the link and you will
open that this page will be open for you
guys and you can enroll here you give
your name number and email ID and submit
and our experts will contact you for
sure okay now also there will be live
classes on weekends for this so do check
it out the link will be in the
description box a CIS space annual total
income is expected to be 103
000 US dollar in the US and with the
average salary of 82 000 US dollar now
we'll move on to the com Tia Security
Plus certification so this certification
cover various topics including threads
attacks Technologies and tools
architecture and design identity and
access management risk management and
cryptography to earn the com Tia
security place certification you need to
pass an exam now I'll tell you about
this com Tia Security Plus exam in
further so com Tia Security Plus
certification covers various topics
including threads attacks Technologies
and tools architecture and design
identity and access management risk
management and cryptography to earn the
com Tia Security Plus certification you
need to pass an exam now I'm gonna tell
you about this course com Tia Security
Plus which is offered by simply learn
it's a widely recognized certification
CompTIA Security Plus verifies
fundamentals of vendor neutral I.T
security knowledge and abilities this
certification program covers the
fundamental concepts of network security
and risk management as a benchmark for
best practice in it security the classes
of this will be held on weekends and you
can also check what you are covering in
this course in this course content page
okay you will find everything here like
attire States and these are the things
that you will learn governments risk and
complaints this is the things that
you're gonna learn on this course okay
so now is the best time to learn this
you can take up this course the link
will be in the description box below
click on the and enroll now I have told
you how to enroll in this course so now
let's move forward to ccsp okay so this
ccsp which it stands for certified Cloud
security professional is last on our
list so let's move on to ccsb if you are
interested in Cloud security and you may
want to consider the certified Cloud
security professional certification this
certification covers topics such as
cloud data security Cloud platform and
infrastructure security Cloud
application security operations legal
and complaints and risk management to
earn the ccsp certification you need to
have at least five years of experience
in the field and to pass an exam the top
certification offered by ICC 2 is the
certified Cloud security professional
training program
by comprehensed information security
concerns and putting data protection
policies into practice this training
will help you reduce security threats to
your cloud storage so I'm gonna show you
so there will be some other courses also
that you can take when you will take up
this course there are certified Cloud
security professional CompTIA Network
plus casm if you are going for ethical
hacking you should take cism but it's up
to you guys you if you want to take
security
Cloud security professional course you
can take that this three are elective
ones you can choose any one of them okay
so there are many other certifications
in ethical hacking but these are some of
the most well known and respected
remember certifications are just a one
way to demonstrate your Knowledge and
Skills it's also important to gain
practical experience and stay up to date
on the latest development in the field
good luck on your ethical hacking
Journey so let's end this video do check
out our cyber security program the link
is in the description box below and also
like share and subscribe to Simply thank
you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here